what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if this
is your first time here my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data data science
statistics and programming subscribe for
all kinds of content just like this and
hit the notification bell so YouTube
notifies you whenever I upload a video a
lot of people in the data science
community we love to talk about
statistics machine learning deep
learning all that fun stuff but we don't
talk enough about communication which is
an equally important thing I personally
think of data science as the
intersection between statistics
programming domain expertise and
communication so it's an incredibly
important piece of the puzzle it's worth
exploring exactly what this means as
well as just some overall good
principles and practices for
communication in data science a lot of
the things in this video that I'm going
to talk about are generally good
practice in any field but there are just
certain specific things that I have seen
data scientists fall into and there are
certain responsibilities that we all
have in the data community to most
effectively add value to our
organizations and to just avoid the
negative stereotypes that we sometimes
fall into of being nerds which we are
but we need to be useful nerds so
without further ado I'm gonna get into
five tips I have for being an effective
communicator in the data science field
as a disclaimer these are just my
opinions they've been shaped over time
by my own experiences and anecdotes as
well as some research so hopefully it's
a useful perspective for you that
provides some interesting food for
thought our first item on this list is
all about mindset and it's about
shifting from thinking about technical
needs to thinking about business needs
most people in the data science world
have an advanced technical degree but
there comes a shift at a certain point
where they have to apply the skills they
learned in school to real-world business
problems that are faced by their
particular industry and now us data
people a lot of us have an instant to
talk about super technical things like
maybe we want to been our continuous
features into category
local buckets we need to do one hot
encoding on our data set and Oh our days
set is structured so that we should
probably try some sort of longitudinal
approach things like that here's the
problem most of our clients honestly
couldn't care less the thing you have to
keep in perspective is that the
technical end of things is only useful
in so far as it can generate information
and value for somebody else and then at
least if you're working in the private
sector that information and value is
only useful if it can generate your
company revenue or savings that picture
is a little bit different if you're
working in the public sector but the
same principles apply just for a
different end goal usually than money a
lot of people you're gonna be talking to
they think about outcomes and the bottom
line all day long and I'm gonna be blunt
they're really busy and they don't have
time to get boggled down with the
technical details they just want to know
that you got to your results in a
reasonable way
and that you know what you're talking
about so in short before you do any
analysis you need to understand what the
purpose of it is and you need to think
about what kind of business metrics or
KPIs that is key performance indicators
that your work is aligned with and to
the extent you can you want to
understand the impact your work has on
your organization as well as making your
results as actionable for your
stakeholders as possible and doing this
is a fine art which does require
developing your domain expertise
somewhat but these are the things you
want to be thinking of as you work on
data science projects the second thing
is to state and be upfront about your
key assumptions this is a huge one now
there are certain things such as
normality for a t-test which are
technically assumptions but are
completely irrelevant almost all the
time but then there are other things
like where's your response variable
coming from what filters are you using
on the dataset which are incredibly
important and are going to influence any
sort of results you produce in a very
dramatic way first of all this is a cya
kind of thing because your work is
always going to come under some degree
of scrutiny
but stakeholders in particular do want
to understand what sorts of assumptions
you're making they're almost invariably
gonna have some amount of questions for
you and just understanding and stating
your assumptions upfront is going to
prepare you for those questions and you
also want to elicit feedback on your
assumptions because once again your
assumptions can influence your work
arguably more than anything else but
it's also just generally a thing that
builds trust too because it really
indicates that you're thorough and that
you ask the right types of questions on
that note item number three is empathize
and build good relationships with your
stakeholders it's important to
understand the meaning of the word
empathy so to do that let's consult my
good friends Mariam and Webster
according to the dictionary empathy is
defined as the action of understanding
being aware of being sensitive to and
vicariously experiencing the feelings
thoughts and experience of another of
either the past or present without
having the feelings thoughts and
experience fully communicated in an
objectively explicit manner the field of
UX that is user experience is centered
all around that idea empathy and there's
tons in the field to unpack so much so
that you can spend months or years doing
it and I'm absolutely not saying that
aspiring or current data scientists also
need to be UX professionals but it's
worth educating yourself a little bit on
how the design thinking process works in
particular one tool that it's useful to
understand or at least be aware of is
the persona this is from an Adobe blog
and they define a persona as an
architect you sir whose goals and
characteristics represent the needs of a
larger group of users they say usually a
persona is presented in a one or two
page document like the one you can see
in the example below such one to
two-page descriptions include behavior
patterns goals skills attitudes
background information as well as the
environment in which a person operates
designers usually add a few fictional
personal details and a description to
make the person a realistic character so
on and so forth so for this particular
persona there's a lot of
formation on motivation personality
goals frustrations technology and again
this is not one single individual it's
kind of a representation of a number of
very similar types of individuals I'd
say the most important things are here
number one you need to understand what
people's pain points are and what they
care about and those real human things
should be the focal point of any sort of
deliverable that you produce some people
are more or less technical than others
and I think it's totally fair to try and
gauge that out on an individual client
by client basis and then of course it's
just a reality of dealing with human
beings that if they know you and you've
formed some sort of relationship with
them they will be way more likely to
trust your work and want to take action
based on it
so yes data science is not a purely
technical field there's a giant human
and psychological component to it that
you're not going to be able to avoid
item number four is to use simple
visualizations visualizations are an
extremely powerful tool the cliche is
that a picture's worth a thousand words
and that's particularly true in data
science and it's also estimated that 65
percent of the population are visual
learners graphs also have the power to
let the audience digest a much larger
amount of information in a short period
of time than something like a table
would allow for and there are some
fairly well-established best graphical
principles out there two books that I
come back to again and again are the
visual display of graphical information
by Edward Tufte a and show me the
numbers by Stephen whew one of tough
days biggest points is that so many
graphs out there are full of useless non
informative junk even coined a term for
this he called it chart junk he also
made a big point about what's called the
ink to data ratio and he really stressed
that as much of the ink on the graph as
possible should be used to show data now
I do think there is an acceptable range
of debate about graphical principles and
it's certainly audience dependent but by
and large I do think most data
scientists / s
the ability of their audience to
comprehend very complicated graphs
I have personally presented information
to clients before who were confused by
scatter plots and I got questions as I
was going through a presentation about
did I control for some variable when
that variable they were talking about
was the thing that was on the x-axis I'm
not saying that to make fun of people or
to insult anybody's intelligence I'm
just really trying to put into
perspective here that more complicated
is almost never good and of course it is
audience dependent I do think that
generally we're moving into an era where
more and more visualizations are going
to be dynamic and interactive so if you
have the ability to put something
together like that and your audience can
very easily understand it then more
power to you do it but if you were to
ask me for some graphical principles
that work the vast majority of time
they're put into practice I would say
the following first of all use the right
graph for the job if you're trying to
visualize a trend of something changing
over time use a line plot if you're
trying to visualize the relationship
between two variables you need to use a
scatter plot etc as much as possible
stay away from pie charts and bubble
charts they may look pretty but from the
standpoint of telling an easily
comprehensible story they suck
use the simplest possible graph or
graphs for the job don't clutter your
graphs up with a bunch of crap and then
above all else show the data and really
think about what story or takeaway that
you want your audience to come away with
then a last item on this list is to tell
engaging stories you can't get away from
the fact that in data science whatever
our deliverable is whether it's a graph
a report a model whatever the case may
be we are telling a story and there's
good and bad ways to tell stories if you
think back to the best stories you've
ever heard what comes to mind for you
chances are at the beginning of that
story you were hooked that as something
pulled you in and then you were engaged
as you went through that is there wasn't
a dull moment you weren't bored and then
the ending was punchy that is it didn't
fall flat at the end well the same
things are gonna be true in storytelling
in data science when we talk about a
hook and pulling your audience in that's
your context you basically always want
to start out by demonstrating to your
audience why they should care
you want to use visuals because like I
said way more of the population than not
can be considered visual learners and
once you've established that context
upfront way less of your audience's
energy is going to be wasted trying to
decipher and comprehend what they're
trying to look for in your output or in
your graph and then you need to end with
recommendations and findings and if
there are any action items you end with
those two don't go out on a low note so
in summary I often describe data science
as being more of an art than it truly is
a science and the communication aspect
of it is one of the biggest reasons for
that but I can tell you that just from
my own personal experience there's a lot
of people in the field who don't do this
part of the job particularly well so if
you can get really good and excel at
this you really have a great opportunity
to shine and to really stand out in your
role so thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it and you'd like to
support my work the best thing that you
could do for me would be to share this
video otherwise at least consider
smashing the like button and then I'll
see you all in the not so distant future
until then Richard on data